hey guys what's up this is andrew for
traincensus.com
so i'm here to make a huge update guys
on amc
friday session was the day where we
actually
reached 35 finally so i'm very excited
to
see with you guys everything that
happened during this week
and give you my predictions for the
coming week
let's get into it
[Music]
so we finally reached 35 guys i'm
calling for this level since i've
actually started my channel
you can go and watch all my videos when
amc was trading between 5 and 10 i was
already talking about 35
so i think the first thing that is
interesting to do in this video guys is
to
remind you how i found this level
so i got it using two different methods
and then
here you can see that i already did a
lot of idiot with counting
it took me actually a very long time
this morning so we are sunday morning
here in hong kong and i spend like
between like one and two hours to try to
you know really find all the different
scenarios that i'm gonna give you
and as usual guys i'm gonna give you my
preferred scenario which is for me
the one that is the most likely to
happen so very
quickly here so 35 let's go in the
weekly time frame
i'm just doing this very quickly because
i think it's interesting guys to
you know stress something that has
worked very well
when it is so that you guys remember
what you can do to find those targets
so very basically it's the all-time high
guys so this is the first
method but this is usually not enough to
actually find the target where you
have like say 80 90 chance to have a
rejection so
this was the first way to do it and the
second way
is just by using fib extension guys
and i showed you many times but maybe
some of you are watching my videos for
the first time
and you probably won't go check all my
videos i did in the past
months and like two three months but
i've shown you guys this method few
times you just
measure the first weight so that's why
you need to associate idiot wave theory
where you do discounting one two three
four five four moves up and
abc three ways for correcting moves
and then once you have your waves you
can measure them guys you measure it and
usually you know the market is growing
and everything that is growing
is following uh in some funny way the
fib
extension ratios and the field
retracement ratio because
fibonacci is just the measure of growth
you can go check everything
about this famous mathematician but
basically
he applies some theory to everything
that is growing and the market
is growing so here we're going to use
his ratios because they actually work
very well
in finance too so to find the fib
extension
you just measure the first wave so i
measure the wave from here
to here guys my very first wave and i
apply
then this whole wave
ratios that i computed as usual using uh
the golden number
1.618 to the bottom of the second wave
so here we have one here we have a two
and the 1.618 is the most likely
ratio to happen and it gave us 36.3
guys so let's see where we went you know
we cannot be that precise when we use
actually this
long-term method but you know it's funny
because it went to 36.7
so you see i had 35 i had 26 and
actually this is what happened so now
i'm gonna
give you guys what you are here for
and what i did this morning so we go on
hourly time frame i'm now gonna give you
all the different scenarios
and try to help you
understand what is coming this week and
in two weeks it's for now
it's very interesting so we have two
different scenarios that can happen so
either
so i'm gonna apply idiot wave theory
again so
here i told you we are in the third wave
guys that's why i knew that we're gonna
have some very strong moves with strong
associated volumes that are going to
take back some major levels so we took
back
all the major levels and we went to 35
actually a bit quicker than i expected
which is good because this is called
momentum so
now the market has a very strong bullish
momentum and the question
we're having is this third wave complete
or not
so to to know that you go inside the
wave and you apply idiot wave counting
the same way we do on the longer term so
here
we have two different scenarios so i'm
gonna start with the bullish case so the
bullish case
is like i told you guys we can break
down this fifth wave
very nicely into five waves as well
inside of the which the third wave has
five waves as well
so this confirms that this counting is
very good
and that i'm gonna keep it in both my
scenarios so the bullish scenario is
that here
we have completed this one two three
that i told you about i told you we're
gonna do the 4 and that at 12 we're
going to have this
very strong impulse that we had so
either this is a
3 and then we have 4 and 5 coming
so if this is the case we can again
apply idiot with theory that says that
when the second wave so i'm talking
about the yellow counting here
so in this counting the second wave here
is a zigzag
you remember guys this correction was a
bit deep deeper than i expected
and usually when you have a zigzag in
the second wave you have a flat in the
false wave so
my bullish scenario is that we do
something like this
so we came back to 26 y26 guys because
this was the level we had here so i told
you
that we're probably gonna come back
either to 26 or 17
for now we came back to 26. we
gonna consolidate guys we're gonna have
here this false wave in my bullish case
that might be a flat it might also be a
triangle we
often have triangles as force waves so
if it's a triangle you're gonna have
something like this
you see you're gonna have something like
this
so either you have something like this
abc
like this is a flat or triangle i doubt
we're gonna have a zigzag
so let's see and my less bullish
scenario is that
here actually this third wave is
complete
so up and that
we are like this i call this the third
wave guys because i want to remind you
what is happening
on the longer term we have this one here
two
and here three so if this is the case
then we're going to have a false wave
that might be a bit longer because it's
a
bigger cycle so then we're going to have
a correction
so here we had between a flat and a
zigzags i'm not sure
we're going to have something like this
all right so in both scenarios
either we have a small correction small
consolidation
that is going to be probably higher and
stronger
so i expect this one to hold above the
26 level
then we're gonna have a fifth wave like
around you know the same time
we need to consolidate for the second
wave so between 26 and
of april and the 7th of may so roughly
10 days so
in the first case we're going to have 10
days of consolidation then we break
35 probably going around the 70 area
or we consolidate a bit more guys we can
stay at 26 but most likely we would go
slightly below
so i'm gonna give you other levels that
you can watch
and then we're gonna do a fifth wave
going as well
to those higher levels so once again to
find
the target of my fifth wave i measure
the third wave
and depending where we're gonna correct
guys you know that's why it's important
to know if we correct only 226
then the fifth wave might go to 74 but
if we correct
to 16 which is very possible if the
correction is actually
if the force wave is the one of the
higher degree wave counting then the
correction is once again going to be
longer and deeper so we might go
here it's like kind of the i would say
not worst case scenario but almost
and then we would go only to 64. so we
need to see first
where we're gonna correct uh what is
going to play out in the coming week so
once again guys i give you
my first scenario which is the one that
is my preferred scenario is this one
so flat or triangle i don't know because
we arrived here with a lot of strengths
so usually the market remembers when you
know you have
such impulsive moves it takes time
before
actually you know before the sellers
find the confidence
to shoot those shares again so
i think that this is what is going to
play out
so something like this we basically
gonna hover around
like you know the 26 35 level
maybe and then do a final wave
and to actually know if this is what is
on the table
we need to find some events that
eliminate
some scenarios so here the event that
would eliminate
this scenario is if we break 26
guys all right if we break 26 on the
fourth time frame
this scenario is less likely to happen
and we're probably gonna have
the second scenario playing out once
again i show you the scenario is that
the one two three four five
is like this all right
is that we already completed the one two
three four five cycle
which is the third wave i'm talking
about for a long time and if this is the
case once again the correction would be
deeper and longer so you have my two
different scenarios and 26 is the level
to watch
uh to know if this would happen or not
okay so let's have a look a bit
at the volume so first so you can see
the
average volume traded this week was 400
million
shares guys so it's a lot and
i want to show you what we have on the
option market
so here once again what i do guys as
usual i
compute i take all the maturities so
from
january 23 the longer one i mean from
june
to january 23 june i think the 18th of
june it's the most liquid maturity to
start with
the first two we had before the weekly
they have almost
no positions so i don't have them here
and i compute the delta
of all these options using the
volatility of each maturity so the
volatility is here guys
you know i just take the volatility and
refinance on every
strike option that i have here and
then i do this formula guys i just
multiply
the option open interest by the delta
which gives me the exposure i aggregate
all this data
and i have here the synthetic short
exposure
so we have we had when amc was at 12
around 10 percent
and amc guys went to 35.
so this made actually the market maker
it forced them to buy a lot of shares
gas because you can see the short
interest
goes from 10 to 18 so we came back to
26.
so we have right now around 1.9 billion
usd synthetic short exposure on amc
which is around 17 million of shares so
you can see that when the market went
from 12 where we had 40 million shares
226
okay so market makers and hedge funds
needed to buy 30 million shares
but here you can see that the gamma
squeeze probably helped
to trigger this strong move up but once
again guys look at the number of shares
that has traded
400 million shares so
it's much more than this all right the
gamma did maybe 10
of this but we had here probably some
hedge funds cutting the short positions
waiting for this data to be released for
now we don't have the short interest as
of the
30s of april so it would be the 28th of
april on friday
because it has not been released yet it
usually takes one week
you know the finra reports so i'm
waiting for this number we had 95
million
of short shares on the regular market
so i'm waiting to see if right now we're
gonna have less or more
if hedge funds actually increase the
position or if they stopped it
so it's going to be very interesting to
know who was actually buying amc when
it went that high and here i would be
happy to see that this increased because
this would mean
that despite the selling pressure put by
hedge funds on amc
the price action still developed higher
in a very very impulsive way
so this would add some weight to my
actually first
scenario once again i show you guys that
this is
a one two three four five like this so
that basically this
third wave is not complete so the only
little
problem i have here is that the third
wave here doesn't
you know it has five waves inside it but
it's not perfect
i don't really like this counting so
i'm really waiting to see more price
action here to get more information to
know
if actually the third wave is complete
or not
it's going to be a very interesting week
once again guys the level to watch
here is 26. i remind you the scenario
that i
foresee the most likely to happen is
something that
we're gonna consolidate here a little
bit around
one or two weeks maximum like the abc we
had here
you know doing a triangle or a flat
correction
so most likely something like this i
don't really know and then we're gonna
have this
fifth wave so this is for me the most
likely scenario so let's see what is
playing out and careful 26 is the level
we need
to trade above if this scenario is to
happen
so guys that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys